[Music]
the next three hours is your chance to
participate in a discussion with one of
today's leading political commentators
join us as in depth welcomes lewis
lapham editor emeritus of harper's
magazine and editor of lapham's
quarterly lewis lapham's books include
the wish for kings waiting for the
barbarians and gag rule his latest book
is pretentions to empire
louis lapham it has been almost 20 years
since you wrote in the preface to your
book money and class in america these
words
never in the history of the world has so
many people been so rich never in the
history of the world have so many of
those same people felt themselves so
poor has that changed at all in the 20
years since she wrote that i i think
that
feeling has become more pronounced not
less so i i think we still have that
notion
that we deserve
more
i mean i think you see that in the
increasingly
widening
disparity between the rich and the poor
in the united states
between you also see it in our in our
foreign policy
more is the
watchword
and
the sense of entitlement
that
passes throughout the
society we
being born american
we deserve the best of all possible
worlds and
it should be forthcoming over the next
horizon or around the next bend in the
river or with the next
election
besides foreign policy that whole issue
of money power
entitlement has been a theme throughout
most of your books that you've written
it it has been and where does that come
from from you i mean where did that idea
come from that you wanted to spend so
much of your life writing about these
issues
well
it just kept coming up i mean i it
wasn't a conscious decision but i mean
you would
i
was born in 1935 and i'm in san
francisco and
i'm in san francisco in 1945 when the
u.n is
established my grandfather was the mayor
who
resided over the meetings that were
arriving to u.n charter
the united states had
won
a great war certainly in germany by that
time you know
clearly it was a matter of time before
we were going to defeat japan
so the sense that
franklin roosevelt's
four freedoms freedom from want fear
freedom to worship freedom to
speak
and we had we the united states had
saved the world
from great evil and
we're going to advance
the doctrine of human rights put forward
by eleanor roosevelt in 1948 so there's
a sense of uh great possibility
when truman comes to
san francisco in june of 1945 it's the
biggest crowd that's ever been assembled
in the history of california
and the sense of bounty and the sense of
as i say a possibility of promise
and this again recurs
with the election of jack kennedy in in
1960.
the young prince hal has succeeded to
the to the throne ask not what
your country can do for you but what you
can do for your country and so the whole
question of
the distribution of
wealth and power and to what purpose
um
what
the sense of
obligation does the united states have
toward the rest of the world toward its
own citizens and so forth
and and the distribution of wealth power
of course is is the
story of politics since time immemorial
i mean this was a
question that the greeks were addressing
in in
athens and certainly the romans
the ancient it's the question that the
americans were addressing in
the time of the revolution and the
writing of the constitution
how to
arrange
the system of wealth and power and
so it seems to me it's a it's a great
historical theme and i was just
following it
through its
manifestation in the
say 40 years between 1960 and and now
and in terms of what you said the the
relationship with with foreign policy in
2003 in theater of war
you wrote that the 50 years prior to
september 11th the makers of america's
foreign policy over the course of the
previous 50 years
had embraced a dream of power almost as
vainglorious as the one that rallied the
disciples of osama bin laden to the
banner of jihad
yeah i think there was a
similarly
grandiose
notion again go back to kennedy ask i
mean
no war too small
the
uh
expansion of the american military
budget i mean to the point where we now
have
um
750 military bases around the world to
the triumphalist spirit that you see
prior to
2001 prior to 9 11 it shows up in the
writings of
charles krauthammer in washington who is
saying that that we essentially are rome
we can do anything we wish
and that the
the shape of the world is
uh
merely a matter of our implacable will
or
another variation of the same theme is
francis fukiyama the end of history
we have reached the only possible
solution history is at an end and from
now on it's only a question of
maintenance
so
yes i mean that and um
that world encircling
vision
that we are the center of the universe
uh
washington is
the center of the universe and and the
world should bow to our will there there
is something
of that same spirit in any uh jihadist
or
quasi-religious
view of foreign affairs i mean you would
find the same
spirit in the
words of pope urban ii when he was
rallying the first crusade in the 11th
century
out to
remove the infidel from jerusalem and
bring the power of heaven to bear on the
uh
misfortunes of the
earth
i want to go back to that uh 1945 period
by your grandfather in san francisco he
was mayor of san francisco mayor of san
francisco and someone once called him
the uh an infrequently loved businessman
mayor i think he was quoted as they
quoted him as being what was it like to
be
to be the grandson of the mayor
well it was very exciting it was it was
my introduction to politics
grandfather had
run on a platform that he would only
serve one term and therefore
would
call
his fairies was he would call the shots
as he
saw them
which he did i mean and
with a result that
the local political machine got very
irritated with him and tried to have a
recall election which he won by a very
handsome majority he was he was quite
popular with the
citizens of san francisco
because he
was extremely accessible i mean he kept
his
his home phone was listed he would talk
to anybody that
called him to talk to people in the
street
and um
but some of the
entrenched interests
got upset with him but
during the course of his mayorality i
got to
go to campaign rallies or
come down to city hall to see how the
board of supervisors
arrived at its decision and also it's
during the period of world war ii
he's elected 1942-1946
and the
so that when the
navy
carriers would come into the bay
i sometimes would accompany
the mayor and the launch out to welcome
admiral nimitz or admiral halsey and the
mayor would be piped aboard and
his ten-year-old grandson would get to
come up to gangway and and that of
course was very uh
dramatic and
impressive
to a boy of town to meet the admiral
and and and the ships would be
clearly having
somewhat the worst aware of having been
in the
battles in the pacific
now um some might find it ironic if
going back a little bit further in um
in your family history your your
great-grandfather was the co-founder of
texaco right i think yeah i think it was
one of the three early
founders of texaco but this one the
great great great grandfather henry
dearborn was the secretary of war in the
jefferson administration he wasn't my
great-great-grandfather he was my
great-grandmother's
great-great-uncle dearborn my great my
great grandmother was a dearborn
and
it is her
family
and henry g dearborn
was a
well he
he uh
he was a man of some many parts he
was from new hampshire
recruited a
60
soldiers the militia
and
fought at bunker hill
and then he accompanied uh
benedict arnold in the when arnold
doomed attempt to try to take maine in
the autumn of 1775
and dearborn showed up everywhere in the
revolutionary war he was at the battle
of saratoga
he was at the battle of monmouth he was
at yorktown when cornwallis surrenders
after the war he's briefly on
washington's staff
then he becomes a member for congress
from maine
and then jefferson makes him secretary
of war in
both jefferson administration
and
after the war
he's made
madison make some collector of customs
in boston
and
and then out of nowhere in in 1812
a message arrives from madison
appointing
dearborn
commander-in-chief of the american army
in the east but there was no american
army
there were various militias and also
instructed him to
march north and take canada which um
fairly peremptory instruction he didn't
manage
to do that but he did manage to burn the
town of york
which is now toronto
and it was
because of the burning of york that the
british took
found that extremely offensive and
therefore burned washington in september
of 1813.
but he was uh
he
very much a career was you know
throughout the whole of the early
american enterprise
how long have you lived in new york
we're actually doing this show from new
york this month i've lived in new york
since
1960. a long time 46 years
and
so you left the west coast when i left
the west coast in 19
end of 1959. did you do what
to come to new york to i had been a
newspaper reporter on the san francisco
examiner and i came to new york in 1960
and began as a newspaper reporter for
the herald tribune
and
then stayed in new york and went from
the herald tribune to the saturday
evening post the life magazine and then
the harper's magazine and
so harper's was what year that you've 19
1971.
and except for a short stint you were
there until last year
yeah i was there until
april 2006
what did harper's have that kept you
there so long
well harvest is the
oldest continuously published magazine
in america and it has a wonderful
tradition
and it published everybody
that you've ever heard of
in
the history of american letters it was
it published moby dick and um or part
excerpt of moby dick in 1851
and then it published
mark twain
henry james norman mailer edith wharton
i mean it's
it's a
glorious
literary historical
tradition
and so it was that it was a feeling for
the
what the magazine uh had been and was
and and
still could become
when did you you were gone from there
for just a couple years i was gone
1981 1983.
and that was a period of time in which
they let you go
yeah i was dismissed in in
81 and then i was re-uh
restored in 1983. how did that happen
well that happened
through
the good offices of
john r otherwise rick macarthur who
was a
the grandson of the
john r macarthur
the big foundation in chicago
and he
was a
fan of the magazine
during the late 70s and and of my
writing and of the kind of
pieces that the magazine was publishing
and when i was
um
it's a little complicated because in
1980 the
magazine up to that point was owned by
the kohl's family in minnesota
they folded the magazine in 1980 but it
was rescued
before it missed an issue by the
macarthur foundation in chicago
macarthur foundation then appointed a
board of directors none of whom knew
anything about the magazine business and
as a result i was
let go
this
alarmed
rick macarthur
who made it his business to
he was then working as a newspaper
reporter in chicago and he made it his
business to come to new york get on the
board of uh
the magazine and have me uh
restored i know kinsley was in during
your
he was he was there during my absence
yeah he was there very briefly
and what is rick macarthur's uh alliance
with harper's today he's a publisher and
uh
as
you know between us we made a
success of it
particularly with the new design after
1984. financial success well i mean it's
i
was never entirely clear on the numbers
but i do know that as of last year it
was at its highest level of circulation
and renewal and newstown newsstand sale
so
in that end of the magazine business it
is a success you know p is people who
have never ever
picked up a a an edition of uh
of harper's
still know what the harper's index is
yeah how did that happen i don't know it
got it got copied
by many different
other
publications and forms of it and it also
i guess gets circulated by
some sometimes on the internet or people
fax it to one another
it became a
a
form that was
much copied did you start it i did and
do you recall where the idea came from
well the idea came during the years the
the two years that i was not at harvest
between 1981 and 1983 i was a successful
two years
if it brought the index right and it
started out i was i was writing and
during those two years i was writing a
column once every two weeks for the
washington post
and one week i
i just made up an index
you know it was a form of a column as a
way of trying to understand the world
all of the numbers and all of the
categories were invented
and it was an entertaining column
um
so that after i went back to harper's i
i took that idea and
turned it into you know the numbers were
real and the categories were real but
the but the
notion was the same to give
insight
into
um
circumstance let me just for if people
are not familiar here's a couple from
the january
um the percentage of americans who say
they support universal health care
over the current system was 56 percent
the percentage who say they would
support it if it limited their choice in
doctors 28 yeah
yeah go ahead well i mean it gives you
those kinds of of numbers i can remember
once
we ran a juxtaposition between the
amount of money that the
american government spends on the
national endowment for the humanities
and the amount that the u.s military
spends on the maintenance of the
uh
its various bans
and and it's the same
number of hundred of million dollars
average number of times president bush
used the pronoun i in each of his state
of the union addresses 36 the average
number of times the president president
clinton did in his addresses
103. yeah it gives you a sense of
bill clinton's narcissism
and there's just some that are just
funny
i mean they don't have
the amount a rhode island man received
in a settlement last year over his
faulty penile implant four hundred
thousand dollars the number of years
that he has had an erection ten
just
no i mean it just who writes these who
comes up with the idea what we have is
we have um we have four interns and they
gather these numbers over a period of
month and it begins by asking a question
or you come across
a
statistic
somewhere in reading
the newspapers or
the internet or a magazine
and then you just keep asking questions
and you you build it that way in other
words it's not
passive
it's not just
letting it happen you you have to find
and and often we start with a with a
statistic that will be given to us by
the new york times or newsweekend the
statistics
often turn out to be wrong the numbers
but they in turn lead to even more
interesting numbers
but it's it's a full-time uh
uh occupation and then we collect uh
you know with a computer we have a great
inventory a bank of numbers and then
sometimes you can
find a match
maybe not that
particular month but three months yes
you also started several other portions
of ian harper's
and they include what they would include
the reading section the notion of taking
found objects in the form of
essays or poems that might be
have
appeared in a very small publication
like say the paris review or
grand street or
london review of books i mean both
domestic and foreign sources
that
and we take that and give it a broader
circulation and
also take trial transcript or take
police testimony or take
letters written to government officials
or
between uh citizens and and
it was a
and the section is called readings and
it runs to about
between say 16 and 20 pages
and you can do wonderful things with it
because there is a lot
written there's a lot said that
doesn't
find a very large audience and you just
lay it out there just lay it out there
but again it works with the same
principle of juxtaposition or
theme and variation
so you can put
various things together and and they
that the two things together uh
add to a sum greater than their parts
where did you learn to write
i learned to write at um
i guess first grammar school and then
prep school i had
both at grammar school in san francisco
and at a prep school in
connecticut i
had teachers who were
extremely strict on
points of grammar
and
so i had to learn to diagram
sentences and um
the old classic diagramming of sentences
yeah and i and also by reading and i had
one
teacher in grammar school who
once a week would take me downtown on a
streetcar to buy a
a new book i mean if i'd done well in in
my week's work the prize was
i got to go downtown and and he
finds some book for me to read and so
it's by reading that you you learn to
write as far as i know that's the only
way to do it you wrote
recently or uh that you thought your
writing was getting better because you
were using less adjectives today yes
that's true i mean it's getting a little
simpler i mean if i read something that
i read back on
um
essays that i wrote 20 years ago i can
see
a lot of unnecessary words and i can see
where i
uh make the mistake of
choosing the
rhythm of the language or the sound of
the word over the
meaning of the word and the
structure of the sentence
michael kinsley said this about your
writing style he said that one of the
mysteries of lewis lapham is what the
hell is he saying when he's writing i
sometimes feel like i'm in a reading
comprehension test and i'll turn the
page and there'll be the question like
what's the theme of this passage
well i think that's
with all due respect i think that's
kinsley's problem more than than my
problem the the um
over
time over the last um
say
30 years the the kind of reading
comprehension level
of the
um
generally speaking in the us has gone
down i mean if you
i read
when i read back in the
uh
history of harper's magazine in in in
in the year 2000 we did a 150 year
anthology
and in order to put pieces into that
collection i i was reading the magazine
in the 1850s 1920s 1930s and so on and
you can see up until
the first up until the second war
the vocabulary that the
writers have
who are writing for the magazine
is
enormous compared to to what it is today
this is a world before television um
they
and they they use these they use
language not
to be pretentious
but there's an abundance of it i mean
they have it's it's almost as if
vocabulary and
and
literary structure
are endangered species i i read
statistics somewhere
that
in 1940 the
average vocabulary of a
american high school senior was
something like
12 000 words and today it's six
um
and that's there is and
you can at that that tendency of course
is exacerbated by television
i i've written for television as well as
for
print
and it's a completely different uh
medium
because with television it has to be
it's like writing dick and jane i mean
it has to be
a subject-verb object and you can't back
into
sentences with
complicated clauses and and
and the tones the various tones of irony
get
lost on television because it's
not of course on c-span but the but
on most television you don't have time
for that kind of
construction and people are interested
in data
and the our journalism of which kinsley
is a uh you know he he's a very uh
bright guy but the
um
the language of
our journalism has become increasingly
focused on on data
in you know
information and not on
style or not on the subtlety of language
um
first i want to tell our viewers that
we're going to open up our phone lines
and invite you to join us lewis lapham
is this month's guest on in-depth we
have three telephone lines he'll be with
us for about two and a half hours more
and for democrats if you would like to
join us 202-737-001
for republicans
2027-37-002 and for independence uh
zero 202-628-0205 we are live this month
in new york city we do not have access
to
um bring you email questions so if you
would like to join us and and talk to mr
lapham use the telephone this time okay
so i want to with that premise on your
writing read to our viewers something
that you wrote recently in your notebook
section just to give people a feel for
you for what you wrote and then you can
make a new action you want to you wrote
this
democracy is born in dirt
nourished by the digging up and turning
over as much of it as can be brought
within reach of a television camera or
subpoena
we can't lay out a new agenda for
america unless we know which america
we're talking about the one that
embodies the freedoms of a sovereign
people
or the one made to fit the requirements
of a totalitarian state we owe it to
ourselves to know the difference
seldom in our history have we been
offered a better chance to learn a more
useful civics lesson and by holding up
to the light the malfeasance non-feasens
and all other rot embedded in the
character and conduct of the bush
administration we might discover what we
mean by america the beautiful like it or
not
and no matter how unpleasant or
impolitic the proceedings the spirit of
the law doesn't allow the luxury of
fastidious silence or discreet
absenteeism
that's not bad
i would say that was so
i i think i was writing that uh
arguing for the
impeachment proceeding
brought
to bear on
president bush and vice president cheney
when did you first
decide
that you thought that the the president
vice president should be impeached
well i
it
i think about two years ago there was a
report by
michigan senator john conyers who was
and it was brought in i believe december
of 2006
going through
telling the whole story of
the
bush administration setting up the
war in iraq on a false premise and on
on what they knew to be a false premise
that this was
a sufficient reason for impeachment
there was a great deal of other
detail but that was the essential
uh
point in other words that the iraq war
was the perpetration of a criminal fraud
on the american people which
i'm sorry i mean congressman conyers
right yes senator
chairman of the judiciary committee yeah
why did i say senator i'm sorry i think
i think you did i meant the congressman
and so i read that report and uh i had
also from the beginning of the
um
iraq adventure i had you know long
before we got to
march of 2003 i had been writing pieces
in harper's magazines suggesting that
the
our response to the 911
was
exaggerated
and there
and the whole notion of a war on terror
was
a war
on an unknown enemy in an abstract noun
and to use the word war was
a serious mistake so
it was coming out of that and coming out
of the
the way that the
bush administration promoted the war
with the aid and assistance i must say
of
most of the american news media
um so i i was
conversant with quite a few of the
points that
conyers was making and also by this time
books were beginning to come out
i think richard clark had written his
book and i think secretary o'neal had
written his book
and
i think bob woodward even had written
his third
uh summation of the bush administration
each time
changing the tone but i mean it and in
the third one i think he was
beginning to smell a rat
so i was not
alone in
by
december 2006 in this
impression this and this was your most
recent book which was really a lot of a
good grouping of your essays on a lot of
this issue and
to show our viewers this um
the cover of this
yeah what does it mean what was the
cover mean
that was
the uh
inside you will find
that that's an eagle
right yeah and then inside in
among the epigraphs at the beginning
you will find
a
song
composed by
former secretary of
former attorney general ashcroft uh let
the eagle soar yeah like she's never
soared before from the rocky coast to
golden shore
let the mighty eagle soar soar with
healing in her wings as the land beneath
her sings only god no other kings right
but then you have to read the other
idea of an eagle ah benjamin franklin
you have underneath it for my own part i
wish the bald eagle had not been chosen
the representative of our country he
does not let his living uh he does not
get his living honestly
he is never a good case but like those
among men who live by sharping and
robbing is generally poor and often very
lousy besides he's a rank coward
yeah so they're two they're two theories
of the eagle and the one of the themes
in in all of my writing for the last
let's say 30 years is the argument
between
the american democracy on the one hand
and the american nation state on the
other hand
and the eagle is
the emblem and representative of the
american nation state
not of the american democracy and so
um
the american people had no quarrel with
iraq
the american for the purposes of the
american nation state
war in iraq
seemed to be a good idea just as the
war that was declared on
in vietnam and the war that was the
spanish-american war so
but that's a theme that runs all the way
through
not only my own writing of the last say
30 years but all the way through
american history
i mean it's the same theme that comes up
with uh
both lincoln and thoreau when they
will have nothing to do with the mexican
war
it's the theme that is
very much present in the writing of mark
twain at the turn of the
20th century in the anti-imperialist
league
so
you asked earlier
about um
you know distribution of wealth and
power that
really this is the theme the the
the american democracy the american
republic the american people on the one
hand
the american nation state the
sometimes called the american empire
sometimes called
the inside the beltway crowd sometimes
called special interests i mean there
have been various there are various ways
of
of um
just
the american oligarchy as opposed to the
american democracy there
but that's the argument that runs
through through our history and and
and through the last
it's the argument that's the
will be the
underlying theme of the next election
does does anybody ever say to you why
are you writing about class and
money when
you went to prep school
your
your ancestor was one of the founders of
texaco
you certainly aren't one who is in need
of cash you certainly run with the crowd
that is
um
one might say is of the elite
yeah but that seems to me that the best
critics of the elite are people who are
themselves
sufficiently well acquainted with the
elite to
see its
faults
and that's the point the point is not to
again this is the argument that
that you can see uh with with the
writing of the constitution you can see
the same argument
in
the first
or the yeah the first century bc in rome
where cicero is talking about
placing his hopes on a ruling class or
what we would call an establishment
that has some
sense of
moral force and does not become
rancid and corrupt elites tend to become
over time
so
vainglorious and self-preoccupied
that they
um
lead the
nation into
big trouble and the uh
i mean
the to criticize the elite is simply to
to criticize
whatever happens at
any particular point in time to be the
ruling governing possessing class and
all societies
uh have a ruling governing and
processing class it's just a question of
how is that class
made
i mean
up until the
what in
france under the
kings or in
england under george iii
that class was formed at birth
by inheritance and based on land an
extraordinary
sense of
privilege this is one of the things that
enraged the americans when in the
1770s
we don't have a system at least we
haven't had as much of a system
maybe we're getting toward that system
of it it's not based on inheritance it's
it's a
more open
um
what we hope to be a meritocracy to let
you still in the end
that what you are making is the
is the ruling in the governing class
that's what
when yale university is established in
1701 it's the the purpose
the announced purpose is to
produce
clergymen and magistrates
capable of governing
both in
temporal and spiritual affairs
the colonies
and yale still
prides itself on that
um
intention
you ask anybody at yale what is the
point of a yale education what is yield
doing and they say to to
produce leaders
and so while other universities i mean
yale has happens to
like to make that announcement on the
but
that is the point of harvard and
princeton and many of our universities
and also the
not just the ivy league i mean it's
we
manufacture
our
ruling class in a
in the same way we manufacture
747s
and that's that's our great uh uh
strength
here did you graduate from yale 1956.
did i read somewhere in one of your
books you wrote that yeah the class and
class ranking in yale used to be
yeah by the wealth it wasn't by what
grades you got no not for the first
hundred years not through the
18th century you were ranked according
to
the how rich your father was and so the
number one student in school was the
richest student in school
but the that's the way the
social
balls
worked in philadelphia
uh
prior to the american revolution i mean
a british officer would be
in philadelphia and
when phil when pennsylvania was still a
colony i mean a
british officer an aristocrat was a
important celebrity in the same way that
prince charles would be an important
celebrity today
if he was somebody was giving a charity
ball in his honor at the metropolitan
museum and the way the dance cards were
arranged
the girls who got to dance with the
visiting officer were ranked according
to their wealth the richest girl danced
first and so
on but that's
i mean money is our great
i mean
that is what
gives one the chance to rise or fall in
the world in the us
it's not it's not birth lewis slap him
our guest on in-depth let's take some of
your phone calls first up is chicago
hello
aye thank you haven't we had wars on
drugs since the fourth crusade uh
as a spice war
and then the iran slave trade
the
boston tea party the whiskey rebellion
the opium wars alcohol prohibition and
uh caller i'm sorry i'm gonna i'm gonna
let you go on that let's go next to
urbana illinois hello
taking my call i said like a few quick
questions i'll just do it really quickly
like uh of course i was wondering uh mr
lab i'm like if you could just like
explain like
the alarm quarterly like what's the the
target readership and like who
what kind of people are gonna write for
it
then uh like
i saw that you wrote a blurb for like uh
theodore krabs book uh the last days of
the renaissance i was just wondering if
you could say like
just like what's your connection with
rap and like how you were approached to
give the blurb
and then uh
that's that's that's true thank you
first lap and quarterly
quarterly is is a new journal quarterly
journal will appear
first issue in october of this year
and it's
the quickest way to describe it is the
great books made topical
it will
be roughly
226 pages it will begin with a theme
that is in the news
first
issue with states of war
the second one will address the the
problem of
ruling and possessing class the third
one will
probably
address the idea of god but and then the
fourth one the idea of money and
so i will write a brief introduction and
then run out a series of texts beginning
with the greeks homer or
and
bring to bear
those texts on the
frame of the present
and that will be the bulk of the
quarterly and
in the
back there will be essays from
contemporary historians dealing with the
same or similar theory or similar
themes or
just talking about the uses and misuses
of history i i happen to believe that
the
uh historical consciousness has gone
missing from
broad sectors of both the private and
public sectors of the american mind
and that
as was pointed out by cicero not to know
what happened before one was born is is
always to be a child so that
the
sense of
the historical context
is what i think
gives meaning to the present and also
makes possible
the
construction of the future first edition
comes out when october
and uh
how do people subscribe
well with the direct mail
some of the direct mail dropped as they
say in the business last
week
i i also have a a website
labhonksquarterly.org
and it could people can subscribe
through the website what's it going to
cost
it's going to cost 60 dollars a year
each issue will be about 15 but i mean
to me that's a fair price because the
each issue
is
the equivalent of a
very high quality paperback
and you you had an interest in being a
historian yourself at one point i did i
i
yes i'm i'm a historian monkey i i
started i
graduated from yale in 1956 and then
went for a year to cambridge university
in england with the thought of becoming
an historian
and i had discovered that i didn't have
the
patience or the temperament
of a scholar
also i was loath at that point in my
life to learn medieval german
and so i spent a year in cambridge and
then came back to the united states and
uh
went to work as a journalist in san
francisco second part of that was color
was about uh writing a blurb for
a book did you i don't know
i do you write blurbs for books
occasionally i do yeah when i when i
know the writer or and i
or when i think the book is good and i
don't know which
i couldn't understand about renaissance
doesn't ring about
which book he's talking about
if he's talking
so but it would be
a case of having
read the book and uh
not everybody who writes blurbs reads
the book but i do
next is queens new york hello
oh hello uh mr lapham it's an honor
um you know i hope i
get enough time here first to thank you
for your long decades of what i consider
a service to
the readers of harper's magazine uh
including myself
you know as both as writer and as editor
i think it's been
great
and you know i was sorry to see you go
um last year but at least you're still
doing the uh bi-monthly column
so uh question
okay um the question was in your uh
long experience uh yeah i wanted to tap
actually into that historical sense of
yours having uh you know especially in
what you've witnessed uh since world war
ii
um about the development of secrecy in
power the secret state the cia the nsa
the degree to which all this
was more private or less private
back
back when you first became aware of it
the degree to which it has been
privatized into networks
of influence
you know is there still a cia or is
there just as a network of connections
behind it
and also if you're willing
to
take a position
on
the various ideas about september 11th
as having come out of
that area of secret power
the degree to which osama bin laden
perhaps is a function of american
foreign policy and 9 11 itself may have
been an orchestrated event not now these
theories about demolitions but in the
larger sense of orchestration
queens thank you mr lapin well there's
certain to answer the questions in turn
certainly there has been since
world war
ii and since the setting up of the
i forget the exact name of the act but
it's the act that sets up the national
security apparatus in 1948 part of which
is the cia
and but many other uh
intelligence agencies intelligence
gathering agencies within the united
states government i mean
i wouldn't be able to tell you exactly
how many there are but they're more than
we suppose
and yes the classification of
information has become increasingly
uh severe off limits to
the american public and and that's been
a steady
progression
over the last 50 years there are there
are far more secret documents secret
correspondences
secret
data of all kinds now than there were
say 50 years ago and and this of course
is
further compounded when you have
bush
putting
presidential papers
off limits or henry kissinger making a
deal with the
library of congress that nothing of his
will be read for another 30 or 40 years
and so
the ability of
people in uh power to sequester
their their own records
uh all of that has is moving in in the
same
direction so it is increasingly
difficult for the
ordinary citizen and even for the
members of congress to find out
what is true and what is not true or
who are our friends and and uh
and who are our enemies i mean prior to
the
uh
democrats winning control of both the
house and the senate
last year
the
bush administration was utterly
unresponsive to requests
from
committees
of both the house and the congress for
for
information
and
as to the
waging of the war in iraq or the
distribution of the spoils to various
american contractors and so on so
yes our government is becoming
increasingly
privatized
and
government
information that
should be
available to the general public
not available the general public as to
the
question of um
what happened at in 9 11
i am reading at the moment a book by a
man named david
griffin
on the
debunking of the 911 debunking and he
raises a number of
sharp questions
i am not yet
which
i think
deserve further
questioning and investigation but i am
not
as yet prepared to
think that the um
bringing down over the 911 i'm sorry of
the trade towers was the
work of the
bush administration
royal oak michigan go ahead thank you
for taking my call mr laven i wonder are
you aware of the report that uh
muhammad albaradi made to the security
council on the very day before bush
gave his 2003 state of the union speech
in which he uh you know used a niger
uranium connection uh muhammad ali
reported on that day that as of
as that of that date he had yet to find
any evidence that saddam had revived his
nuclear weapons program that was
discontinued in the early 1990s and
another question is that since that
january 27 was the day that the bush
administration one of the un inspectors
to report to the security council that
john river ponti i assume was present
and then i asked you to comment on how
he could sit behind colin powell
by he on february 5th 2003 when he was
asserting that these tubes were to be
used for making nuclear weapons and i'll
hang up thanks thanks michigan
well i mean i'm i'm not aware of this
precise conversation that you mentioned
but i am aware that the bush
administration knew
that the
evidence that it was putting forward
to
justify the invasion of iraq was false i
mean
certainly powell
knew
that he was not telling the truth on the
um everybody knew there was no
connection between
hussein and al qaeda
i can remember having a conversation in
the winter of 2003 with hans blix who
was the
in charge of the u.n
weapons inspection and was clear to him
that the
any
nuclear
ambition on the part of hussein had been
abandoned
for quite a few years so
it's clear on the record that the
the bush administration
was
operating on on false premises that they
knew to be false premises
philadelphia hi
i'm going about hello
go ahead you're on the air sir good
i calling about the
question
regarding the 20
october 2002
agreement from the congress to give the
president the authority
to go to war if necessary and the will
of resolutions are written in the un
which allowed
the which it almost it was a an
invitation the united states to do
something about saddam hussein
does he agree that saddam hussein's
falling was a good event thank you
yes that was part of the
sales pitch on on
the part of the bush administration and
it was sold
to the congress in
october of 2002 there were some
notable
exceptions a speech made by
senator byrd from west virginia in which
he you know actually says to the his
fellow members of the senate fi fi on on
you for
granting the president these kind of
powers on the basis of practically no
with no justification at all but most of
the
members of the congress for whatever
reasons
accepted the
sales presentation put on by the bush
administration and part of that sales
presentation was the
connection to al-qaeda
next is
springfield illinois hi
hi um i'm very happy to talk to you mr
latham uh i've followed you for
the last 20 years and i think you're one
of the least known one of the greatest
writers of your generation
i have two quick questions for you i'll
actually maybe won't be quick the first
one is do you consider yourself
a journalist
versus being an intellectual
and the second question a question has
to do with class
i just finished reading a book called
the global class war by jeff faux and in
that book he postulates that the middle
class upper middle class and blue collar
workers
are facing ultimate demise because of
the uh interaction and uh between the
the the global elites the very wealthy
um extreme wealthy the extremely
powerful uh uh corporations and their
leaders and
very powerful
so i'd like for you to comment on on
that postulate
thanks springfield
answer the first question i consider
myself an essayist more than a
journalist
or an intellectual i would simply say i
was i was an essayist
and an amateur historian
the
in answer the second question
certainly uh
the evidence suggests at least in the
united states that the middle class is
is beginning to
dwindle and that we are dividing
ourselves
to i expect to be our eventual sorrow
between
the rich and the poor
neither the rich and the poor have much
interest in
you know working government
the rich can take care of themselves and
hire their own
security forces and their own
air transportation and their own
information networks and their own
residential
enclaves
so that they don't necessarily have much
interest in
for the
infrastructure
the the commonwealth the common
infrastructure which is on which the
national enterprise is based
and the poor are usually in such
pushed so
hard against the wall or
day-to-day
existence that they don't have time
to
work at the mechanics of the government
and
i think i think you probably i don't
i would be very interested to read the
book but the
you see what happens when the middle
class uh
vanishes and this happened in rome um
it got to a point where the
the republican
magistrates the people who administered
the republic and then continue to do so
during the
first century of the empire
these people begin to um
disappear
and the
running of the military is
no longer in the hands of the citizens
it's been outsourced to
gauls vandals
syrians
egyptians and so forth
and the same thing begins to happen to
what were the
roman public services and
if you lose a middle class you you you
you lose it you lose democratic
government
2001 you came out with this book a
lights camera democracy and i ask you
that because you mentioned earlier bob
woodward and you wrote
about him in this book
you said this as with politicians and
oil company lobbyists access is all and
no journalist in washington over the
last 20 years has played the courtier's
part more gracefully than bob woodward a
managing editor of the washington post
the famous author of many books the
model of the heroic journalist played in
the movies by robert redford woodward's
work and reputation
rest on his gift for ingratiating
himself with anybody in office or power
with whom he can trade the favors of
secrets kept and rumors revealed his
celebrity as an investigative journalist
i.e the tireless champion of liberty
pacing ferociously to and fro on the
ramparts of freedom is one of the better
jokes
of american journalism
i think that's true i mean i think
woodward is an extremely accomplished
uh hannah gyrist or
what would be
a court here i mean he's a man who
knows how to play
how how to
find his way to the ear of power and to
channel that into a
dramatic copy i mean
i could be wrong about this but at
the best of my
knowledge and recollection in the
all the president's men book there is no
named source
and the uh
and then i think of the various um
woodward books whether it's the one
about casey is the cia or the one about
powell when he was the uh
commander-in-chief or the secretary of
state i can't remember when it came but
or the one about the supreme court in
other words it's always coming from from
an interested source that uh
woodward manages to promote and i think
he's written three books on the
bush administration
first one is
bush is a hero and you know takes his
orders directly from god and aren't we
lucky that we live with such a great man
i mean essentially that's the tone of
the first one
the second one is beginning to have some
doubt and i believe the third one is is
now
taking the position that these people
have
made a mess but by that time the the uh
the uh the shift of
opinion has taken place i mean woodward
is a man that has his um
you know he's a weather fan
from which way the wind is blowing he's
very good at it but the
um
and it's a kind of journalism but it
isn't a journalism that is totally
dependent on
sources sometimes anonymous armada
michigan hi you're on with louis lapin
good morning i mean good afternoon
uh can you hear me okay
hello
hello yes
uh mr lapham uh i've been reading you
for a number of years
i am
i'm of the age i came back
i'm a carrier from world war ii and i
was called back into korea so i won't
get into the worst thing
there was a yesterday book notes had on
a speaker for the heritage foundation
what he said with in essence was
he was in favor of bush's preemptive war
and then he will go down as the great
president
uh which i
don't agree with
uh um and the other thing i want to say
is i'll just talk a minute uh brian had
a guest on the other day and the best
one of the best things i've heard in a
long time randy
wrote says we will never have a
representative government
unless we stop this campaign huge money
we have to have campaign finance reform
which i agree with
um
i re uh what got me interested i've been
following you for years
i first read wish for kings
and uh correct me if i'm wrong um
i believe right now jim baker was a
secretary of treasury for reagan
at the time of the bank scandal
and yes that's right yeah okay he
resigned he left there
he went to texas
with a bob moss baker and himself and
they
were put to set up the election of bush
41 that's where the big money started
the hundred thousand dollar contribution
the rangers
and um
big money hit big time and then 41 was
elected
uh with the help of ales and atwater and
the willie horton thing uh uh
george bush
can you i'm sorry can you kind of wrap
that up in a question for mr lapin i
want to say quickly we had bush uh
numbers rocked after the 91 war and
a baker resigned the state again he went
over the white house with moss baker
again
and i'm sorry
thank you very much for your call but
we're going to keep moving on if you
don't have a question smithtown new york
hello
yeah good afternoon
it's a pleasure to talk with you folks
i'm really enjoying this interview i
have a question um mr lapham you
obviously are well educated and have a
breadth and depth of experience
and i was curious you had brought up
topics on say the greeks and the romans
you've mentioned vocabulary and
writing sentences
do you have a list of books that you
would consider
required reading for somebody and if so
is that something that you had planned
or could plan on using your quarterly
your bathrooms quarterly for
yes i i i do i mean i i'm constantly
suggesting uh
books to people and uh
it's it's by no means comprehensive it
they just happen to be books that i'm
particularly
fond of or attracted to i mean
one of them would be
i
yes if you send if you get hold of me at
the quarterly i can i can give you a
list also our viewers uh you have given
a list to us which we will be showing to
our viewers during an upcoming break
includes uh edith wharton yeah herman
melville
uh let's see
yeah dennis theater um
vladimir nabakov barbara tuchman yeah
when you look
what is it about these people that have
that synthesize for you
something that makes your favorite book
is it the writing is it the topic what
is it it's it's it's the writing um
all of these people are are people who
have a
distinctive
voice and style
and
rise above the
simply the
base i mean
they write with
i think force and grace and i and that
is what gives
meaning to their
work you wrote someplace that when you
pick up
a piece to read
you give it three pages and if you can't
if you can't hear a voice in three pages
that's it that's it
if i don't hear a voice
and uh
i'm not quarreling with with
what kind of a voice i'm i'm not
quarreling with the politics it's not an
ideological uh
decision but it's a question of is this
uh writer
writing out of his or her
own
thought feeling experience observation
is he or she trying to
get at a truth of
one kind right whether there are
obviously infinite numbers of truths as
there are infinite numbers of stories
but what gives it
coherence and meaning is is
my being able to
hear um and writing to me is more a
matter of the ear than it is of the eye
um
that
that voice of of somebody struggling
to
uh get to the
um
the truth so as you're reading this are
you reading it aloud
no but i'm hearing it a lot you're
hearing it a lot yeah
next we have a call from uh
winston-salem north carolina hi
yeah i'd like to ask mr maple a question
please um
all in 1970 71 i just got out of college
and i went to washington to work
in the civil service area and
i was involved for a good while there in
what we will call the white house
complex the
executive office building
new executive office building that type
of thing
and
it's just uh a neophyte so to speak i
observe that egotism plays a big role in
politics a lot of times
and uh later later i came to find out
that uh
maybe some of this resulted in what
we'll call watergate so to speak when i
came back to go to graduate school and
watergate broke and all of that
i'd like to ask you do you think egotism
played a role in the iraqi situation as
far as between literally between the
bush family
and the saddam hussein family
and
you know with saddam being in power from
the first iraqi war to the second iraqi
war and you would see him on television
every once in a while smoking his big
cigar and waving his sword and shooting
the rifle in the air and all that wasn't
that an embarrassment to the bush family
and uh actually the administration mr
cheney powell so to speak and uh
have you ever heard anything
thanks north carolina we'll leave it at
that it'll happen well i would say that
egotism and vanity has is always
a prominent
part of
any political story
the
desire
for men to rule over
other men is
you find that
from the very beginning of
written records and
i don't think one would go into politics
without a strong sense of one's own
ego
and hoping to find in the
applause of
the public or the
votes of the electorate
some
a mirror in which
the politician can see
reflected
the
proof of his or her own glory
i think ambition
is
uh and
the wish for
fame renown such celebrity however you
want to
whatever word you choose to use is is
always
present in uh
in all politics i mean this
clearly moves napoleon as it moved
julius caesar as it moved adolf hitler
and as it moves george w bush
next washington d.c
good day how are you all
i'd like to give two harper's index and
read the principle six of the number of
principles if i may
one is the millennium aids project says
10 billion dollars per year to stop aids
in africa
now we've spent 400 billion dollars
committing genocide in iraq killing at
least a million people this time
um
james baker spent 100 billion dollars in
1991 as secretary of state buying the un
vote that's from washington post article
is very clearly defined
now last is principle six of nuremberg
principles written by world war ii
veterans
the crimes here and after set as
punishable crimes under international
law crimes against peace planning
preparation initiation war progression
in violation of international treaties
agreements and assurances to participate
in the common planner conspiracy for the
accomplishments of any of the acts
mentioned under
one
two war crimes violation laws and
customs reward would include but not
limited to murder ill treatment of
deportation of slave labor or any other
purpose help us out here help us out
here what are you trying to tell us read
nurnberg principles number six
why deportation why caller because we
are required for this law ma'am
and i think it ought to be published or
gotten out to the public and use we'd be
finished by now that's how short it is
okay thank you for that we'll go next to
mount prospect illinois hello good
morning good morning i'm honored to be
able to speak with you
i have a somewhat lighter question
included in your list of books is a
discussion about the beatles and
i was curious if you could reflect about
the time that you were in india and
why you
wrote this book so many years later on
in just a little bit about your
experience there thank you
in 1968 i was a contributing writer to
the saturday evening post and the then
editor otto friedrich
sent me to
rishikesh in india to spend
two or three weeks with the beatles who
were then
the greatest celebrities in the western
world and
their every movement was a matter of
extreme interest
to
many prospective readers of the saudi
post and the
there they were uh on an ashram above
the ganges river in the foothills of the
himalaya mountains
with
a
guru by the name of the maharesh
sorry the maharishi mahashiyogi
and
they were there for a spiritual retreat
and i managed to
introduce myself
gradually up the hill of the same ashram
and spent two weeks
with about 60 other people of whom the
beatles were
clearly the most
important
and so i got to know them slightly i
didn't um
press them for
interviews or for
their thoughts on the meaning of life
but i
would be sitting at the same
um table or attending the same
meeting with
one or another of the
teachers
of what was then called transcendental
meditation and there would be
you know it was it was very beautiful it
was
overlooking the river it was uh they
were
the
lodgings were rural
um
did you learn how to meditate i learned
how to meditate there were i i had there
were many monkeys in the trees and
i had a pet monkey that would follow me
around because i would
take care to
feed him
generously
and
i learned something about the indian
philosophy
and
something about
music
does indian philosophy have something to
teach us
yes it does the uh i'd studied it to
some degree at uh
college
and um
i'm not
yes
i would think it would and do you
meditate today
uh no
next is largemont new york hello hello
um i had originally tuned in
at the time when
mr latham was discussing bush's
impeachable offenses i thought that i
was the only one in america that thought
that there had been impeachable offenses
which for some time i was listing but
it was too aggravating to go on
and that
you know
i is has is there anyone else out there
i am horrified that i am not literate
enough to be
uh
to know you to have read you but uh in
terms of
groups of people and organizations and
whatever to pursue this i i am appalled
and amazed
about
the kinds of things that have gone on
that i i have found to be the most
incredible
high crimes and misdemeanors and i take
this seriously i was well trained in
school and
civics and i
held office locally for three terms
and my oath of office was the same as
his
um
i couldn't have done those things but
this is basically i'm spitting it out as
best as i can because while you wait
you're talking about other things so
thanks very much if if you had a reader
who wanted to read about your feelings
on the impeachment of bush would would
these be the two books
that would uh certainly yes those two
books but there are also many other
people i am by no means alone i mean
there there's the congressman john
conyers report there have been
uh
there's a book written by a man named i
think john nichol
there there you can go to the moveon.org
website and find
a number of uh
motions to impeach and
there there are a lot of people who have
had the same thoughts as that caller
and the
they haven't been much noticed in the
mainstream press but the
there is a large uh body of
feeling on that topic in uh the review
of theater of war one of the reviews
that was written by peter preston of the
guardian weekly the british organ
british journal they wrote this
is lapham an adornment to american
journalism absolutely is his critique of
wars not worth
fighting perceptive and exhilarating
often better than that why then do he
and his fellow sages sit on the
peripheries under any administration
democrat or republican because in part
they choose to because the sidelines fit
their sense of rectitude and superior
self better it's a terrible shame how do
you respond to that criticism i don't
even i don't understand what the man is
saying i mean the the uh
the
the observer the writer the essayist is
by definition on the set lines i mean
i'm not
a uh
a politician i mean presumably he is
wishing that i were
um
running for office
but it is the it is the role of the the
sas and the writer to
to write and and
to do so
in in public to do so
in a magazine or on television or on the
radio is is a very uh
civic uh
uh a gesture i mean
so i i think
i really don't understand what that
what he's after they say arizona you're
next
uh
arizona
please go ahead
um i have three
very short related questions that i'd
like to ask
first mr lapham what do you see as the
cultural implications of the iraq
adventure for the western world
with its judeo-christian tradition
second is there indeed a danger of a
genuine clash of civilizations
and third
is there in a europe particularly a loss
of faith in its tradition which makes it
exceptionally vulnerable
thank you i've read your column for
years i hope you continue
mr happen
well
i think there is a
i can't i'll just talk about the third
one i mean i i i think there there is a
sense of
uh loss of faith
in in
in europe if what
the caller means is is the
christian faith i mean you
i read in in the
press that that
there
the attendants in the catholic churches
and both in italy and in
france are down and that the
vatican is
concerned about the loss of
christian enthusiasm and doctrine on the
part of its european parishioners and is
therefore directing
much of its effort toward
uh africa and uh
and latin america
i can't uh
i don't
see the uh
so that that is true
and and this of course is the
uh
basis of the feeling i think
with respect to sarkozy's
attitude toward
admitting turkey into the european union
the clash of civilization i don't see as
clearly i mean i see the
the war in iraq
being
more about iraq than it is about
a clash of civilizations between islam
and the united states i mean this
is it's about
power with that with we go back to the
question of distribution of wealth and
power with but it's within the
uh
the islamic uh
religion i mean it's the quarrel between
sunni and shia
it is the quarrel between
iraq and iran if you can remember in the
1980s there was a prolonged war between
iran and iraq
and possibly this will
encompass saudi arabia or syria but but
it's that kind of
it's about local politics more than it
is about a clash of civilizations
uh spring island south carolina hi
hi thank you for taking my call mr lapin
in general are you optimistic or
pessimistic for the west and the battle
of ideas between it and islam and in the
long run can we both endure thank you
the answer is yes we can both endure and
the
um
the answer is optimistic
i mean i mean that
we will
man it the west will manage to reinvent
itself i mean the the great talent of
the west has been its
openness to
new idea new technique
new forms of communication
and the um
i was recently reading a book by
this is a current book called
by a man named cullen murphy called are
we rome
which is a fine
fine book which i recommend to you the
but he
presents
the notion of
he addresses the question
is the american empire like the roman
empire
about to decline and fall
and his answer to that is yes and no it
in it's
his point being that america has
reinvented itself and
more than once
and so has the so has the west i mean
the the america that
of the
1787 in philadelphia
no longer exists
neither does the america of abraham
lincoln
nor does the america into which i was
born in 1935 i mean the
um
i believe one of the great
american historians henry adams said no
american
ever dies in the country in which he was
born and that's true so that we have
a chance to
reinvent
what we mean by
america or by
civilization
or by globalization
and
so in the long run i am
the the reading of history it gives you
the sense that
new ideas
appear
religions form so do states so do
families and
and over time
we
salvage from the wreckage
of families or empires the
tools which
which
with which to build a new future
and i think
we will have no choice
what else can you do
to our viewers who are interested in the
uh in what mr lapham is reading and who
his favorite authors and favorite books
are in just a few moments we're going to
be showing you uh a list of his of of
those things and so you might want to
grab a pencil piece of paper it's kind
of a long list and so you might want to
uh to do that in order to take down some
notes
you have lived you said in new york
since when 1960
and you have how many children three
tell me about them
my
oldest son is
34 years old andrew who is now
living in toronto and he is himself of
the
well he's at the moment he's the father
of three children under
three and he's about to have a fourth
child under three has
there are twins in the
arrangement
and he's in the
financial investment business in in
toronto
married to a
canadian woman
my
daughter the canadian woman is the
daughter of brian mulroney right yes yes
caroline uh is the is the daughter of
brian mulroney who's the former prime
minister of
canada my daughter is 31 and she is
living in her name is delfina and she is
living in
rome
and is now the proud mother of a new
baby
which she's
very happy with she's married to an
italian prince
and the my third
child
winston is in new york and he is in the
investment business and he is 25.
winston delfino where did those the
names come from
name your children
just like the
my wife liked the sound of of the names
how long have you been married
i've been married 35 years
so you were you're 72 now yeah i'm sorry
so you were about 37 or so i was 37 when
i got married a little later in life a
little later in my by choice yeah by
choice i mean i by that time i was
understood but i was
i was i was ready and and uh
and willing and
thankful
to be married which is uh and i also was
i wanted to be
um
have children
next is new york city hi
hello
good afternoon i have a question a short
question mr lapin
is he aware of any credible efforts
underhanded for collaboration with
israel in a preemptive attack on iran
that would force the united states into
federal complete and war
thank you
i'm sorry i didn't understand that
didn't understand all of it but he was
talking about a preemptive war on uh by
israel on iran
well i know that's been
rooted about and
talked about and in turn
similar to the
israeli preemptive
strike
in iraq
some years ago
but all i know is what i've read in the
in the papers i have no um
special information who's the best
essayist you said you in in life you
consider yourself an essayist versus a
journalist or or an intellectual in in
in our history
oh in our history well i would say uh
i'm usually going to always say mark
twain because i i think of him twain as
the finest
or the greatest of the american writers
that i know of
and he wrote in so many different forms
i've read you know he wrote novels he
wrote
burlesque he
wrote columns for newspapers sketches
and so forth and
i know he's written some essays and
i would
i guess i would just
on blind faith and instinct
say that about duane and but certainly
uh bernard devoto
to me is
bernard i've written this column for
harper's magazine
it's been called notebook over the last
30 years
but
during an earlier formulation of harpist
magazine it was called the easy chair
and it was written between
1935 and 1954
by bernard devoto
and his essays to me are
truly magnificent i mean he's a
writer he has a
great
sense of style his book 1846 year of
decision
which is about the american westward
migration is as good a book of american
history as i know
and i'm i'm truly
i re-read from time to time devoto's
essays and harper's magazine and i think
that
if i was
really good at it that is what i would
try to become is the essay dead
no yes it isn't dead at all i mean the
not only in harper's magazine but the uh
you find it in the new yorker you find
it in the atlantic you find
a short form of essay today is the
is the op-ed page piece that is in fact
an essay it's it's
it's much
reduced
but we live in an age of
digest and reduction anyway so no the
essay form is uh
very much alive and well
louis slapham is our guest this month on
in depth in depth and um we're going to
now show you a little bit about where he
works and how he writes where he writes
when he writes and also the list that we
promised you we'll be back with more of
your calls in just a few moments
my office now is is on irving place in
in new york city
it is the office from which i'm
organizing the publication of a new
uh
publication a quarterly journal lapham's
quarterly which will
devote itself to
historical texts of one kind or another
four times a year we will take one
large subject that's more or less in the
news whether it's
war or
atheism or
division of church and state
or
education or the dream of utopia some
topic that is
under the headlines
and i will write a brief introduction
framing the past
in the present the present in the past
and then
the quarterly will run out a series of
maybe
50 or 60
texts on that theme
from
writers in the archive of
western civilization as well as writers
from you know the chinese and
middle eastern traditions a typical
writing day i come in in the morning
my office 8 30 9 and try to write
up until noon
and get done however much i can get done
and then use the rest of the day to read
manuscript talk on the telephone
think of further ideas
sometimes when a deadline for let's say
harper's magazine is very close i will
then
work all day on the
on the writing but i i try to do it for
three hours in the morning
i started out
when i first left college a long time
ago wanting to become a historian
but i didn't have the
patience for
graduate school
i became a journalist and now i have
returned
to
my
delight
in
history
as an editor
you
the excitement is is to
essentially say to the reader
uh
look this is a wonderful thing to read
read this and
you will
take pleasure in it or you will
be glad you did i mean
that's the whole
impulse
of being an editor i mean you want to
find something over here
that is extraordinary or
exciting or
entertaining or
what leads to the discovery of
self or
one of the riddles of the universe and
then
take it from over here and
present it to the reader and say
behold a
child is born i've always got two or two
or three books going at the same time
it's at the moment i'm reading
the memoirs of william tecumseh sherman
i'm reading re-reading one of patrick
o'brien's novels
i'm reading a book a new book called are
we rome by a man named colin murphy
and
i'm also reading a history of genghis
khan the learning of something
to me is is
an
antidote to
cynicism or despair or you know i mean
it's a
if you're
feeling
lost or depressed
the the best way to
get around or over that feeling is by
learning something i think i mean it
doesn't matter whether you're learning
music or whether you're learning
chemistry or how to assemble
airplane models or
how to play
better golf
but but the notion of
of learning
is an excitement
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
here's a look at some upcoming book
fairs and festivals this weekend book tv
covers book expo america in new york
city the publishing industry's largest
annual trade show
and next week we'll cover the chicago
tribune's 23rd annual pritters row book
fair
the two-day free outdoor literary event
is the largest in the midwest
next on saturday the 23rd head to
manhattan central park for the new york
book festival which hosts book panels
storytelling circles and signings
then july 5th through 7th mark the
fourth anniversary of the freedom fest
from las vegas
also in july the tokyo international
book fair asia's leading publishing
trade show
then in september burnsville hosts the
carolina mountains literary festival
which includes writing and publishing
workshops also in september go to
vermont's largest city for the third
annual burlington book festival
and later that month it's the national
book festival in washington d.c
sponsored by the library of congress and
first lady laura bush
please let us know about book fairs and
festivals in your area and we'll add
them to our list email us at book tv at
csband.org
here are the 10 best hardcover
nonfiction books from the new york times
the list reflects sales for the week
ending may 19th
first on the list god is not great it's
christopher hitchens argument that
religion is man-made and murderous
then walter isaacson with his new
biography einstein
barbara kingsolver follows with animal
vegetable miracle which recounts her
family's year eating only homegrown and
local food
debuting in the fourth spot plato and a
platypus walk into a bar
thomas cathcart and daniel klein take a
humorous look at the various schools of
philosophy
ishmael bayed describes his drug crazed
killing spree as a child soldier in
sierra leone in a long way gone its
fifth next pope benedict xvi explores
the identity of jesus seen through the
gospels
presidential courage moves up to number
seven michael beschloss profiles nine
presidents that he says were brave
enough to make unpopular decisions
george tennis memoir at the center of
the storm is eighth the former cia
director says he warned the bush
administration about al qaeda prior to 9
11.
then where have all the leaders gone
former chrysler ceo lee iacocca on
american leadership
and rounding out the top 10 is john
feinstein tales from qschool his look at
the pga tours qualifying tournament
where golfers vie for a spot on the pro
tour
to view the complete list visit the new
york times website at
nytimes.com and click on books
we're back with in depth with lewis
lapham
you
were quoted by ruth conov in a piece
last year saying that cigarettes are
life itself
i still smoke connie that's your
question i mean i know it's
unhealthy on the other hand uh when did
you start
i guess i started when i was in college
and
i gave it up once for about three months
and then decided it was
such a pleasure that i
returned and you take a lot of heat for
it
increasingly yes i mean sure i mean
there was up until about
10 years ago it was considered
perfectly standard as it was in the
movies i mean i now understand it in the
movies
if somebody is seen smoking the movie
has to be
you know rated x what do you think about
that well
i think it's
i think it's an exaggerated response i
mean i i
i don't think secondhand smoke is that
damaging and the
also
in terms of
whether or not one will contract cancer
or heart disease is
i don't i don't think that there is any
unnecessarily
clear
connection
clearly it is
smoking is
not as healthy as it might be but the
i don't think it is that presents the
general population with as much
risk as as some of the anti-smoking
people would suggest
you uh we've been talking about quite
heavy issues of war and
issues of the government but you also
have written some lighter books i've
written writer books and many of the
essays and the
the recent ones also have um
a good deal of humor in them yeah and
what what about the writing with humor
why is that important to you and and is
it difficult
is it difficult for a writer to find
that middle place to talk about
something as serious as
war and foreign policy and still use
some humor
well it is difficult in this country it
is not so difficult in england or in
france the
there's a
fine book
currently out by a man named clive james
called cultural amnesia and it's a
collection of his
essays and and
reflections on
numbers of
important people in the 20th century
it's a
fine piece of work
and he makes that point that that in in
the us
we are we tend to be suspicious of
a writer who uses both humor
and
and to make a serious point this of
course was
um
also a problem for twain to some degree
because twain
um
has
a truly marvelous sense of humor and it
becomes more acerbic as he as he becomes
older
but he keeps it away from his
persona as the
lighthearted
man in the white suit from from the west
and
will rogers
could do it many of the writers in in
the 20s and the 30s
eb eb white writes with a with a great
deal of humor so does james thurber but
and they are
addressing serious topics
but again after world war ii we begin to
take ourselves
seriously
we
we the as the americans didn't take
ourselves quite so seriously before we
became masters of the universe and the
supreme military and economic power
after world war ii and also the
with the
construction and demonstration of the
atomic bomb we now
hold in our hands the
powers that once were assigned to god
and so
you begin to get a separation in in the
us
there are other serious subjects or
there are the light subjects and
and and
never the twain shall meet
so that you could go to
a bookstore and find under the catalog i
mean under the sign humor you can find
both bold tear
and garfield the cat voltaire wrote with
a great deal of humor so did dennis
dieterow
so did franklin by the way if you read
franklin's
letters
you find that they are filled with a
a
it's not stand-up comedy
but it is
his
approach to the world his sense his
tolerance his sense of understanding
is very much informed by a sense of
humor and i think that that is what
gives
perspective so that
you know even though i am
writing
essays that take a
somewhat bleak view of american politics
i'm not
suggesting that this is the end of the
world because
again that's what the study of history
provides
it it instills a sense of humor 2000 i'm
sorry yeah well it makes you understand
that the other people have been
confronted with similar dilemmas and
that
it makes you less harsh on your own um
generation
2003 you put out 30 satires i did you
know with a blurb from lisa simpson on
the front that's true i have a picture
of louis lapham on my binder lisa
simpson the simpsons that's right that
that appeared in one of the episodes of
the simpsons
so that over the course of time i mean i
some months i write a an essay that
that you know takes a fairly high
tone and other months i write in a more
light-hearted vein and earlier in 1999
you wrote lampam's rules of influence
what did you what were you trying to do
here
i was writing a satirical
self-help book
how to conduct oneself in
a society to achieve
self-advancement
and success and so on and these kinds of
books of etiquette
were
common in the 18th century washington
writes one
and of course so does franklin in his
that's part of the
composition of his poor return series
for example first impressions you write
the first impression
is always the last impression which is
why it's always important to wear clean
shoes you don't wish to be remembered as
the stain on the rug that that's true
that is true
and
but you go through here everything from
grant proposals to insolence to on being
seen to
the best people which under which you
write you recognize them by their
clothes not their character
well that is true i mean you
if you
read the celebrity pages or if you read
the
society pages you you would
you wouldn't be far wrong drawing that
conclusion people comment on your dress
as being
that you dress meticulously that you
dress
very well is that something that you
just that you enjoy doing or is that
something you've cultivated
no that's just something i got in the
habit of doing when i was going to i
still come out of the
in the 50s when i go to school and and
college
it was still
fairly formal one
always had to wear a coat and tie and
i can remember
in new york
in the 50s that
a woman
wouldn't think of going
into the streets
without wearing a dress and in some
instances without wearing gloves
men were wearing
suits and i can even remember where
they're still wearing hats and the again
you can see it if you look in the if you
look at the films that are made in the
40s and 30s you can see that
and i
learned that as a young man and i never
gave up the um
the practice
you um mentioned earlier that you've
written for television
right tell us about your documentary
that you wrote
i wrote well which one i've written two
of them right
the one you wrote on class
that's the more recent one i wrote one
in 1989 on the history of american
foreign policy in the 20th century i
made that one for england
british
channel four it was a six part series
and the second one is called the the
american ruling class which
i made
two
three two years ago it was at the
tribeca film festival
and that is a
that comes out of the book on lapham's
rules of influence
and it is
part documentary and part
musical and part
dramatic
fiction
it's a combination of it's a hybrid form
which was a great deal of fun to make
and i i start with the premise that i
have two
graduates of yale university and so the
film starts
in a quadrangle
at
yale university on a graduation day
and here are these two students they
were not in fact yale students one one
was an intern at harper's magazine and
the other was a
relative of the producer but they were
both the right age and they
and they had a
they could play themselves in other
words they were not professional actors
and the premise is that
okay you've graduated from yale and to
to what purpose why have your
parents
sent you here and paid
forty thousand dollars a year whatever
it costs for yale graduate
graduate
again it could have been harvard it
could have been duke it could have been
stanford
and
again we go back to the point of the
american elite it's to become part of
the elite it's it's to open the path
toward
wealth power and influence
whether in
the corporate world or the financial
world or the political world or the uh
state department and
the
the make to become a maker of america's
uh
culture so you take them around and
introduce them i take them around i mean
they
i say listen you're you you have a
chance now to become
members of the american ruling class and
they say well there is no such thing as
a ruling class in america this isn't
anything you know
this is an egalitarian
society and i said well
yes and no i mean it has a more porous
opening to the
higher echelons
but there still is a a ruling class and
if you if either of you gentlemen decide
you want to
make an inspection call me up and so
they come to new york
and i
give them the grand tour
we have a clip of it let's show our
viewers so you can respond to it
jack this is a great venue to ask about
the american ruling class and while
you're here tonight jack there's certain
rules that would be useful for you to
remember first seek out the acquaintance
of people richer and more important than
yourself and don't take an interest
people who can't do you any favors when
you yourself become rich and famous
then you can collect friends in the same
way that nike collects prize athletes or
that philip ii of spain once collected
four can you really buy a president in
this can you really buy the president of
the united states
where were you educated
so what do you what do you recommend
that a young man
setting out in the world
in america do today
what are the options
well you could
make humanity proud of you instead of
ashamed by doing what
by doing something virtuous and and
the christian descriptions how's that a
virtuous behavior not bad at all
we've been trying to discover if in fact
there is
an american ruling class
i'm afraid there is i don't think it
serves democracy well if that is true
but i think there is
the ruling crash is the rich
who
who
really command
our
industry our commerce our finance
and those people are
are able to
so manipulate our
our democracy
that they really control the democracy
i feel and that's the way it really is
monday august 3rd 19th
[Applause]
[Music]
one other question
should he try to join it during the
class by all means
the more sensitive to our democratic
needs who join the ruling class
the more successful our democracy will
be and the more likely it's uh survival
so did you script all this or was this
just something that uh
that you kind of did on the fly with you
well some of the scripted the in the
scene that you just saw that takes place
at the 50th anniversary of the paris
review
it was just after george plimpton who
was the editor of the paris review had
died
and
but there was still this enormous
what they call revel
in uh cipriani in new york on 42nd
street it was a it was a handsome
celebration and
the elite of new york of various from
various uh
strata i mean you saw there was walter
cronkite but there was also kurt
vonnegut and there was also charlie
rhodes and was also peter matheson
and here was a
an opportunity to introduce one of the
young men in the in the film to what i
was talking about
and but it is completely uh
unscripted in other words i
walter cronkite had no idea that i was
going to be there and what what he says
about the american ruling class is right
off the top of his head i mean without
a note without
prior
uh thought and the same thing is true uh
upon i get in the same thing is true all
the way through the film i mean i write
the
the
the voice overs and a lot of the
connective
tissue
to get from one scene to another but
then when i
managed to bring the young man into the
presence of among others
james baker
larry summers who was then president of
harvard or
bill bradley or
pete peterson
it is entirely
or arthur selzberger actually appears in
one scene to the
publisher of the new york times
and it is
because it is the the young man asking
the question
the
people answering the question are not
suspicious of
betrayal at the hands of the liberal
news media so they so they
they answer the questions very um
straightforwardly and that's what gives
the
film its
strength let's get back to some more
phone calls
louis lapham is our guest and he is our
guest this month on in depth we are live
from new york city we take our first
call from cape cod hello hello good
afternoon it's a delight that uh to see
you and to hear mr lapham
mr laflin would it be impossible for me
to ask you a question actually about the
magazine
no no
i don't think anybody has asked you
about that i've been reading it for at
least 15 years
and i i miss the art on the cover
who in the magazine did was that your
decision to put those beautiful pieces
of artwork on the cover
yes i mean well well in part my my uh
together with the with the
art director
but but that is not one you're not
referring to that number this would be
the newer one a new one yeah well i'm
looking at a picture of my june 2 2007
issue with george bush on the cover with
a cowboy hat on no i appreciate that
that's going to sell some magazines but
i miss the artwork
well the artwork is still there from
from time to time i think
a couple of months ago you would have
seen a cover of
william shakespeare i believe they did a
they did a uh
a lead piece on shakespeare and you i
think you would have seen a painting
but it i i had more
um
preference for painting than i did for
a
photograph and
more in the sense of illustration and
then a sense to sell the magazine
but
again that's a matter of
taste and i think you will find that
there will be more
paintings on the cover from time to time
what about lapham quarterly well
apparent squirrely which is a new
historical journal that i'm
beginning to put together will have both
painting and photography
next naples florida hello hello i am
interested in the education and grammar
he talked about because i too
thought i got a lot out of my grammar
teachers and through the years the
schools have had um
no writing for our kids generation and
now they're letting the kids write all
the time but they'd let them spell any
way they sound and and not worry about
grammar or punctuation or anything i
would like him to comment on that or if
he thinks any kind of writing is better
than no writing and my other question is
all the biographies recently of the
founding fathers and founding mothers
and
even though they had their egotists and
their infighting they still were
magnificent statesmen and gave so much
to the country and i wondered if he
thinks there's any hope for the future
in finding men like that and women like
that
lewis
louis
i think there is a hope but i think that
the it's can and i think it's connected
to language the the uh
the early founding fathers are all of
them
historians i mean they're all
they read i mean and they write well
and
democracy
is about
really really reading and writing
because it it's
the ideas can can get quite complicated
and so can the arguments and it's about
being able to
express
one's thought
either in speeches or
on paper and and you find
that we have that
talent uh
to an extraordinary degree when you
think of the
uh not only the writing of benjamin
franklin but the but the writing of
abraham lincoln or the writing of teddy
roosevelt
the
and it continues throughout the
all of the
19th and
much of the 20th century and
that i i have
we published in harper's magazine some
years ago
the
examination paper for the eighth grade
in a
small town in kansas in 1895
and what they were asking those students
to do
the today's seniors at harvard i i don't
think would have been able to answer
even half the questions
this is why
the first thing that was done usually
when
americans were settling the west was to
build a school
it's why
lincoln in the 1860s
passes the land grant
college
bill i mean the point is that democracy
only works with an educated
citizenry
and the the circumstances have changed
since the advent of
television and since the
we haven't yet really found i mean we
have the internet which people can use
as a means of communication
at which they become as fluent as they
are
talking on a telephone but it which is
good but but the
but it hasn't yet evolved into a
literary uh
form of address or even a form of
address in which we can
truly invent
a new
political
dispensation i mean i was asked by an
earlier caller
about the hope of the civilization of
the west and
but before the
there can be a
revival or a restoration or a triumph or
a new beginning however you want to
address that question
it has to first come with language
and
how we find that language out of the
material that we now have which is
to the most part electronic and either
internet or television
i i think we're still
involved with the discovery of a new
technology
but we haven't yet made that technology
into a
as expressive
of form as as we might hope either from
a literary point of view or from a
political point of view do you read
blogs
tv blogs i i don't know what forms it
will take the i i'm highly influenced in
my thought on this subject by marshall
mcluhan who wrote a book in 1964 called
understanding media
and he begins with the premise that
we shape our tools and then our tools
shape us
and
at the end of the
15th
century comes gutenberg with his
printing press
and for a while it's it's but it's
another hundred years before you get to
shakespeare and montana and
cervantes
and there's a great deal of objection to
to the printing press by the then
established uh
scholarly class which are
for the most part uh church people
have been dealing in illuminated
manuscripts and want to have a monopoly
on on the means of communication it gets
out of their hands
and now
the the internet is out of the hands of
the
the schools
and
so
i don't know who teaches
grammar
in a way that that i was taught grammar
but it's almost as if we have to find a
new a new language
let's go to georgia next hello
yes um good afternoon
i wanted to ask if you're familiar with
and your opinion on
a book by arnold toynbee in 1947 a
civilization on trial
in which he um
kind of warns about the rapid spread of
western civilization
awakening
what he
termed the
slumbering
neolithic populations of the world
and
what that
would entail for
advanced
advanced
civilizations
any knowledge of that
i can remember having read that but i
read it so long ago that i don't have
the
frame of the argument clearly in mind
but
a number of other people have made the
same points i mean i've read jacques
barzun on the same subject i read oswald
spingler on the same subject i read
george orwell on the same subject
many people from many different points
of view
have remarked upon the
deterioration of what they would call
civilization but then you have to bear
in mind
that the civilization that they that
in most instances they're talking about
is is a civilization of the elites
i mean it's based on an elite
premise um
by the few of the few and for the few
and when you
base it much broadly much more broadly
on a democratic basis
certain kinds of standards
get lowered
but again this is the problem uh that we
face which is to find the language
to make a civilization
with the new tools that we now have at
hand haverhill massachusetts
yes thanks connie mr lapman uh there's
an awful lot of angry democrats out here
who are really disgusted with the
democrats because of their just for
instance their recent vote on the uh
iraq war caving into the bush and uh
also we have one instrument and that's
the impeachment and conviction of a
president to remove them from office in
the senate and the very first words come
out of
uh speaker pelosi's mouth was after the
old six election was impeachment's off
the table well she's sending bush a
signal don't worry nothing's going to
happen to you we're not going to
investigate you this is even before they
had uh in any uh hearings uh your
oversight hearings on the health
judiciary or the senate committee so uh
in other words
what president will ever be impeached if
uh the process of impeachment against
any president for doing uh high crimes
mr dean uh misdemeanors
oh
well
i don't know if you were listening the
early part of the program but
connie earlier read a passage
from a column that i wrote at the time
that pelosi
made that statement on coming to
washington and saying that impeachment
was off the table which i thought
the point of the column was that was a
mistake
because if
if this wasn't the time to impeach the
president then there never was going to
be a time and and the
the
again the trend over the last
not just the bush administration but
beginning
since world war ii has been to
center more and more power
in the hands of the executive to
override the doctrine of separation of
of powers
may not
congress hasn't declared a war since
world war ii and the
so
i think
given the
again a subject we've been talking about
the distribution of wealth and power and
placing more of it in the hands of the
executive
takes it away from the
senate it's the senate's constitutional
duty as i understand it to impeach
bush i mean
not
for personal reason but because the man
is clearly
harmed
the american
body politic
i mean to remove
bush is it is comparable to removing a
tumor from a
an organism the organism being the
commonwealth of the united states
but there is
i again given the given the flow of
events
toward an increasing
concentrations of power in
in an executive
branch of government
the chances become more and more
remote
presidential candidates you wrote last
year of hillary clinton i don't have any
respect or regard or hope for hillary do
you still feel that way
well
i i don't
you know i think i've probably changed
that attitude i mean i
i can't where did i actually i'm sorry i
don't think i wrote that you did not
write it you were quoted in an article
uh in the progressive that was written
by ruth cahn if it was a quote that she
had
you saying
i i don't remember writing that because
that that would sound a little too uh
peremptory and i don't usually
um yeah my apologies it was a quote from
you according to her article
well
i may have said something like that but
i i i
i think you have to
respect
hillary clinton for her
knowledge concern
civic mindedness willingness to
undertake
the life of politics
she's a very
bright woman but i don't think that her
thinking is in any way um
new i i can't expect her i don't expect
her to come up with
anything other than a um
revision of
this
she's very much part of the status quo
part of the system i mean there's
nothing uh
revolutionary in her
approach i mean and
what
i hear from the various critics not only
of the
both on the democratic and on the
republican side is the
the wish for some form of new thinking
or some
somebody would say something
clearly and effectively and and
that would give a hope for the for the
future and i don't think
at least i haven't heard that from any
of the candidates this this time i was
thinking of john edwards and his
thoughts of
maybe not specifically ruling class but
haves and have-nots does that mesh with
what you're that matches in part yeah i
mean the but again i haven't paid enough
at least this early in the campaign to
what edwards is saying but the
um
to
say
okay we we are in this uh
place and this is what
we are trying to accomplish these are
what this is what politics is about
politics is not about
saving souls it's it's about
making a common infrastructure which
includes social justice as well as
the the building of
of roads and the setting up of such
bodies as the
securities and exchange commission and
the coast guard and
clearly defining
what it is that politics can and cannot
do and certainly i would think
health insurance would be
part of that education would be part of
that the greatest
resource
that the country has are its people
and anything that you can do to
strengthen that resource
which would be health environment
education to me
does a great deal more to
preserve enhance
the national security than the
investment in
military
adventure
franklin tennessee hi
hi i just wanted to make the observation
that i do think there is a
ruling elite in this country it is
jewish it is very wealthy and it is very
left-wing
indeed 126 of the forbes 400 are are
jews and uh they're only two percent of
the population of the us and they
control about 22 percent of the wealth
mr lapin any reaction i i
i would disagree with that i mean i i
realize that there are many very wealthy
um
jews and that they control
that those individuals or
groups of individuals control large
corporations some of them in the
in the news media but i i would not say
that the american ruling elite is jewish
by any
measure of the
if you look at the
corporate world if you look at the
uh maybe not the individual
wealthiest but if you look at the
structure of american corporations
american law firms the lobbyists in
washington
the people that
are around
president bush the
people who contribute large sums of
money to the
republican party the so-called rangers
and the pioneers and so on
i would think you would find that it was
a
a multicultural uh
collection of wealth wealth
would be a common
denominator but
i i do think it is
more diverse
kosovo pennsylvania hello
hello i have two questions
what
do you think
about the emergence of black water
the paramilitary mercenary force and its
threat to democracy
since it's subject to no
constitutional restraints and the fact
that throughout history
despotic movements have relied on
private
mercenary forces
and also
picking up on the title of your latest
book
pretentions of empire
wouldn't you agree
that
this is a continuation of manifest
destiny of the doctrine that
uh
our country has the god-given right
to do
whatever
we please uh starting with uh
taking over this land from uh the native
americans and it's just continuing
throughout the world
thanks coach phil mr lapin
well that's both those questions are um
a very
interesting ones the
as i understand the um
i'll take the second one first
the
americans i think conceived of their
empire as
the continental united states
much of the
movement west is is done by
um
aggregations of private individuals
moving moving west in as
in terms of
almost random settlement i mean it is
not done
with by the united states cavalry i mean
the cavalry
figures in the story but it we're not
talking about the
the roman legions and and you also have
many people in the united states among
them
as i said earlier thoreau and lincoln
who are objecting to the notion of
war with mexico
as far as overseas empire is concerned
um
that
the western settlement is is the notion
of clearing a a frontier
wilderness and
most of the
native americans certainly in the east
in new england are are destroyed by
disease very early on
rather than by um
with weapons well i think
uh early forms of
smallpox and typhoids typhus kill
something like eighty percent of the
indian population in in the eastern
seaboard
you can make that argument about
westward the course of empire which of
course is the big painting in
capitol hill in washington
in the in the capitol building
empire's a different um question and i
think that we become an empire
you can argue that both ways though the
mexican
sorry the spanish-american war
is an elective war in which the imperial
interest in the east
very clearly
wishes to take over
cuba and the philippines and
make
america a great imperial power this is
what twain is constantly are it's a
argument
on the other point the outsourcing of
the american military and putting our
military forces more and more in the
hands of private interests is
a
ominous
trend i think i mean the
romans find themselves doing this
relying after the republic which
where the military is is consists of the
to a large extent the
citizenry both the
the peasant farmer and the
the more opulent upper class who
young men must
learn to go to war and
that's the way they achieve
political office and they're part of the
of the republic as the empire
begins to decay
more and more of the military function
is assigned to mercenaries whether
they're
visigoths or
vandals or
syrians
people imported into the
empire to do the
to do the heavy lifting
and and the armies become private i mean
you have caesar raising his own army and
so does pompey and so does crassus and
and
it's who compare who could pay for the
surgery
i think i don't know the number but we
now have in iraq i i think that they
give the number for the american
military as a hundred and thirty
thousand i think that's right
but there is another at least fifty
thousand maybe more than that of
private uh
contractors
more and more of our military is is
being outsourced as are more and more of
our government functions
i mean there are now more
private
law enforcement officers i mean law
enforce not officers but
security guards there's more private law
enforcement in the united states and
there is public
and we're giving we're privatizing the
the prisons and
in some cases are our border patrol so
and if if the
history of you know of the roman empire
is of any
has any analogy you can see that
once once the government begins to
privatize itself
it has
less and less
chance of serving as a
democratic republic it becomes the
creature of
demagogue or wealth or
some form of private interest
cleveland hello you're next hi
hi uh three questions all related to one
subject
what do you feel is that can you
elaborate on the connection between the
bush administration and the oil industry
and then the connection between oil and
the war in iraq and third why doesn't
the mainstream media spend any time on
this subject thank you
well i see a very direct connection
between the bush family and the oil
industry i mean not only in houston but
also in
saudi arabia and i would think that the
oil was was if not the
primary uh
motive for our invasion certainly
one of two or three uh
primary concerns i mean in in the
book written by
secretary
paul o'neill who was
briefly the secretary of the treasury
appointed by bush and
he comes into office and as early as
2001
bush has just taken office given his
first inaugural speech and soon
thereafter
o'neill attends his first cabinet
meeting
and is astounded to find people
talking about the
possible invasion of iraq
and also they're
spread out on the table are
maps of all the oil fields in
in iraq and and who's got interest in
what and and uh
you know have the french got an interest
in this or the germans in that and
and the
as you can see the the
american government
our
coalition
made it a condition on the setting up of
the
iraqi
constitution
that the control of the iraqi oil
resources be placed in the hands of
foreign
owners consortiums whether american and
and and or european so
and
again
to make another point for the
should probably
drive the nail unnecessarily
into the point but
several years ago i can't remember what
year i was at the
virginia military institute in um
i believe lexington virginia
bmi bmi yeah anyways vmi yeah
and
i was there for a two-day conference
discussing american military strategy
and foreign strategy and i can remember
a briefing by
a colonel in the
u.s army
who we're in a seminar room and he puts
up a great big map of the
central asia a map that included
uzbekistan
kazakhstan
afghanistan
and
pakistan and he
he just drew a big circle around the uh
that all of those countries and he said
for our purposes we can just
think of all of this as pipelinistan
so
the answer the short answer to your
question is clearly the
control of the
middle eastern oil resource
iraq's
was
among the chief
reasons for our
going to war
queens you're next hi
uh yes sir on the other hand yes you are
sir
uh connie thank you for suspend i'm a
big fan and missed a lot from uh
i'm a buyer of your work although i
don't agree with you
100 of the times in the immortal words
of
ronald reagan i'd rather have an 80
percent friend than a 20 percent enemy
listen i'll make this quick i'm a
lifelong republican i voted for george w
bush twice in
2004.
uh my question is
uh i was also a big fan of
cheney when he was in the first bush
administration his lifelong work in
government i thought he had the
experience of the know-how and when
our current president george w bush
was elected he set up his cabinet
around the old hands
the so-called old hands called powell
cheney
and
rumsfeld
my question to you is
i'm hanging on my fingernails
my frustration
with this administration what chance is
it i'd like your opinion
what chances
of it that
our current president
would not tap into the enormous
knowledge and experience of his dad i'm
42 years old i asked my dad
for his opinion my dad is 74 years old
from the smallest to the largest issues
i would rather they come out and say
hey
we wanted to iraq to get rid of a bad
guy who's planning wmds
and plus
we need oil so we find a more resource
alternative resource
we need
access to the oil
we're a great country without oil we
come to a standstill i would be okay
with queens
thank you queens
well i i think a lot of people will be
okay with that with with the uh with the
with the caller's point if the if it was
put that clearly i think a great many
people in the united states would
understand that and and you can then say
this is the kind of country we are we
are not this uh we're not
um necessarily uh uh
uh
everybody's friend but in order to to
remain the most powerful country in the
world which we think is
for a benign and good purpose we need
oil i mean
that argument could have been made and
could be
persuasive and there are people
willing to make it and possibly among
them
the first george
bush
i take his point and and i can
understand his frustration i mean and
this is one of the
problems that that
we are having both on the republican and
on the democratic side of our political
argument as to what is it that what is
our objective what what do we really
what do the words mean
and
if somebody can
you know explain that
clearly and
honestly i think that that person would
have a good chance
i want to go back up to a journalism
question um or your career question
which is that it's been about i think
about three years now since you came
under some criticism for peace you wrote
tentacles of rage
in which in which inside it you you
mentioned um what was going on at the
republican convention when in fact it
hadn't happened yet you took some heat
for that
was it was it fair
no i don't think it was fair i think it
was
the
misunderstanding on the part of the
people who got excited about that
what in fact i was doing
what what
i it was one
sentence
and i was writing in
july
for an issue that was going to appear in
september
so i was writing as if the
that the um
september dateline was on
what was was current
and i've done this before with with
columns
but you were writing about what you what
was what was being said at the report
but it wasn't mentioned but i didn't no
i didn't quote anything at this time i
simply said that the
the um
that the the kind of rhetoric that would
be uh
that was coming out of the convention
and
which was true i mean it turned out to
be uh
exactly as i had
predicted it would be because it was
such a
you know it was a part of the
um
political decor i mean you would
describe just as way you would say
the balloons were in the air because you
knew the balloons were going to be in
the air and you would say that the
rhetoric was in the air because you knew
it would be
and it's
so i didn't i didn't think very much of
it but the
but
some people got upset and i well let me
explain yeah yeah our viewers an example
jack shafer and slate said every over
tax journalist phones in from time to
time but few dare to make the call from
a parallel universe as lapham did and
then step forward to rationalize it this
moxie runs through the whole essay and
it all too often informs whole issues of
harpers which has grown increasingly
pompous and predictable in recent years
well i mean that is um
uh
that's an attack on the
the substance of the article
that did not run all the way through the
article
but um
schaefer objected to the premise of the
article which was that the
there is a
large
the making of the republican message
machine which has
been taking place over the last 20 years
which
involves the bankrolling of the
intellectual policy right
by
organizations like
heritage and american enterprise and
weekly standard and murdock and and so
on so
it's the
shifting of ideas
toward the right which has been going on
really since the middle 70s but becomes
um
a flood during the reagan administration
are you saying that there's an increase
of this or because there are also there
are also organizations on the left that
fund
but they're nowhere near as
effective or as good at it as the uh
they keep
saying that they you know they've been
this
why can't we on the left set up
think tanks as as effective as the
american enterprise institute or
heritage or any number of others and
they're
they haven't been able to do so because
the
republican right although it has
different elements to it i mean there's
a difference between the you know the uh
cato institute and and between the
american enterprise or between
some of the policy institutes they have
and also but the religious
element
but they can get together and act in a
concerted way in order to
promote
a republican agenda that everybody will
more or less recognize and work with
and the left has never been able to do
that i mean they
they tend to
argue with each other and
and now this of course this is what the
papers have been talking about for the
last
few
weeks about the
uh crumbling of the republican alliance
and and the
factionalism beginning to show
around the issue of immigration
as well as around the issue of iraq and
so
but i mean schaefer was was disagreeing
with the premise of the essay
and used the
that
sleight of hand at the beginning
to
discredit the entire essay which is
that is
that is a customary
form of criticism but but but i think
that's what it was boise idaho hi
hello
it's a pleasure to speak with you today
mr lapham
i was wondering if you could
speak to
the
dangers
this president's
usurpation of power with his signing
statements
executive orders and talk about the
entire doctrine of the
i believe it's called the unitary
executive
what that may mean for
for any future presidential
power and what if anything that can be
uh done to reverse this precedent
thanks boise
i i addressed some of that
in to a previous caller just a few
seconds ago there is
and i said that there has been this
trend toward the centralization of power
over the last um
20 odd years and
that impulse is always present i mean
all
um
it was present in in the
kennedy administration and if you
remember arthur's listener i believe
wrote a book called the imperial
presidency and the um
senator fulbright wrote a book called
the arrogance of power i mean you can
find this impulse whether you're talking
about the administration of franklin d
roosevelt
or
john kennedy or or richard nixon
but it has become more
pronounced
over the last 20 years in association
with the shift
of the american political argument
toward the right
where the emphasis has been less on
freedom of expression and more on law
and order and
and a
a rising tide of uh fear and paranoia
that the united states is under attack
from enemies at all points of the
not only the geopolitical compass but
also the moral compass which was the
substance of the culture wars of the
1980s and 90s
and
so
the move toward the centralization of
power is defensive it's um
i think it's based on a certain
fearfulness and
the wish to build impregnable
ziggurats and
bureaucracies of such
size and magnificence as to be
invincible and and the um
i think it's it's it's a it's a it's uh
it's dangerous because it tends to be uh
based on uh fear and and gets in the way
of trying to find a
a as some of the other callers have
discussed a new
uh
a new
form of let's say western civilization
or democracy or or the uh
you know the
getting to the resource of the
intelligence and imagination of the
american people
the
so it's bad news because it uh
it's a sign of retreat
and
it
the only way to correct it is to
elect
more people to the
senate to the to the legislative side
who will
take seriously the
doctrine of separation of powers and
and
and
try to
enforce
and live up to the
their constitutional
obligation
to
exercise
the power of the legislature
i don't think the hope is going to come
from the supreme court
because the
supreme court seems to me to be tending
in the same direction as as the
white house and that's no accident i
mean toward the
contrast concentration and
centralization of power
every month the first sunday of every
month we invite an author who has a
large body of work to come and sit with
us and take your phone calls and talk
about the talk about their writing louis
lapham has 13 books
what's your next one
give you just i don't i don't have the
next one you don't have a next one not
yet is that good or is it for the time
being because i'm concentrating on
on doing
the
lapin's quarterly the journal and
once i get that set up
i'm
i'll
write another book i may write a book
about the
i
i don't yet know we'll take a call from
peoria hello
hi i think many moderates liberals and
anti-war activists are being fooled by
the so-called benchmarks being included
in the latest
funding legislation one of the key
benchmarks is to get iraq to privatize
its oil
and the current privatization laws
written by american oil consultants
it forces the national iraq
oil company to only have 17 of 80 known
oil fields the remaining two thirds of
the known oil fields and all yet
undiscovered ones we up for grabs by
private oil companies the world but that
probably means united states firms
no other nation in the middle east has
privatized its oil saudi arabia kuwait
bahrain and iran definitely limited
usage contracts to international oil
companies for one or two years but the
12 billion dollar
support the troops legislation passed by
congress requires iraq in order to get
reconstruction funds from the united
states to privatize oil resources and
put them up for long-term 20 to 30-year
contracts
so where the these things sounds benign
that oh torah we have these benchmarks
and there's terrific liberals and
and moderates and interactors are being
suckered into this thing and actually
forces them to divest themselves oil and
what's the united states discount with
their oil it's very it's disguised and
you are exposed to your news in your
magazine in your column i hope you dig
into this and expose these phony
benchmarks
thanks caller any thoughts you know he's
right
and and uh
i i would hope and i think that we have
a uh
a an article already in hand
for harper's magazine coming out and uh
saying this
but i i agree with a minute as i gave an
answer to a prior caller about the our
oil interest and
and my point was that
that
we had
imposed on them or required iraq to
write a constitution giving up its oil
to foreign interests
and i don't think they'll agree to that
so so the benchmark is completely
fanciful
lj georgia uh thank you connie great
show mr lapin i'm a very strong and
enthusiastic supporter of governor mitt
romney for president and it looks to me
like with all the billions of dollars of
fork barrel spending in government waste
it would be important to have somebody
like mitt romney a highly successful
businessman to manage the government and
do something about all the fraud waste
and abuse and i'd like to have your
thoughts on that thank you very very
much
well i don't know anything
of substance about romney i mean i again
from my point of view we're still very
early in the election side uncle so i
haven't
really
i'm not fully
prepared with romney's positions or
acquainted with his
record but the
but sure i mean anything that you can do
to reduce uh
waste and corruption is
is good
whoever can do that whether that's a
a businessman or a former state governor
or uh
a politician of any a lawyer i mean but
but those purpose that objective is uh
admirable in in no matter who's
hands have you ever voted for a
republican yeah i voted for uh
eisenhower i voted for uh
bush to be in the first
the first uh george bush election
yeah in i'm scared sorry for this the
son george bush
the father
next is van nuys california
hello
go ahead then ice
hi mr lapham
what i
what i don't understand for someone
that's lived i'm 68 or 72
is that uh every war
in this last half century well actually
throughout our entire history has been
based on lies
lincoln trump lincoln was uh uh
attempted with the spot resolutions
to stop the mexican-american war which
was based on a lie about where our blood
was shed
uh mark twain who
and was not elected because he was
unpatriotic mark twain tried to was an
anti-imperialist member of the
anti-imperialist league and wrote great
stuff on what happened william randolph
hearst managed to overcome everything
with his phony pictures about the maine
we had that war
now this war the iraq war has been going
on for 17 years which nobody seems to
acknowledge the gulf war we killed 200
thousand iraqis were retreating after
the war was over the sanctions 1991 to
2003 one million five hundred thousand
died twenty five percent of them
children mostly from a lack of medicine
that would have cured diarrhea from the
tainted water
uh
and now the iraqi freedom which no one
seems to mention the lancet
journal anymore they don't seem too
willing to accept the most valuable
thing that's
been analyzed by this war where at least
650 000 have been killed that puts us
over two million equal to the korean the
vietnam war
uh cambodia leos
we are a warrior society and the people
that are most responsible are the
soldiers why do we honor the troops in
this wars my big question when in
vietnam we made them ashamed
if 9 out of 10 people killed in war are
now civilians why do we honor troops for
killing women and babies
mr 11 well he raises a number of
questions which are which are good yeah
most wars are
founded on lies i mean and i think you
would find that uh
true uh
over the course of the last 2000 years
that you'd find that true more often
than not
certainly the
well
i don't think uh
well
i don't know certainly world war
our participation in world war one was
was based on a great deal of false
reporting
uh on the part of the american media and
a part of the american government as to
what was at stake in the war between
germany and on the other side britain
and france
there's a lot of deception on the part
of the wilson administration
there is
some deception to get us into world war
ii
i mean i i think it's fairly
well understood that the you know the um
franklin roosevelt
was aware of an imminent attack on pearl
harbor
but that we needed
something like of that sort in order to
enter the
european war on the british side which i
think in
retrospect was
a
fortunate
decision
the
but but but it is generally so that wars
are are built on lies
what was his last part of his question
i can't remember i can't remember either
he was building up towards the that
whole point of of war and
and lies but i'm not sure exactly what
his final point was i can't remember as
far as i i think i agreed with his
foreign his last point but i
oh i'm sorry it was soldiers soldiers
were responsible why do we
i disagree with that i don't think we
are a warrior society i think that we
that goes back to the
it let's go back to the revolutionary
war it is
very
hard for
washington and for the
uh
colonial armies to to raise troops
i mean in order to get uh
militia
volunteers for the continental army
the government was having to give give
grants of 160 acres
of land
and the
in the division there were maybe a third
of the
people in the colonies in in the 17 late
1770s on the side of the american
patriotism a third indifferent and a
third
on the tory side
but there was always a
problem with recruits
for us
and the battle of yorktown of course is
won by the french i mean and
but
his question about why he we shouldn't
honor people who kill children i think i
see okay
i i don't i don't know whether we are
honoring people we we um
we've always had a
tomb of the the i mean the tomb of the
unknown soldier i believe is
established in 1921 the memorial day
um
um
idea comes in at the end of the civil
war
um
sherman was not
hesitant about killing women and
children in the in the south the um
wars
in the 20th century wars involved
more killing of women and children than
might
than prior i mean there are more
civilians killed during the wars of the
20th century in our military
we killed a great many
women and children and both in dresden
and
hiroshima and nagasaki
so
but i don't think that again i go back
to the point about the interest of the
american
democratic republic and the interest of
the american nation state and
the difference between those two
entities
the long-standing argument between them
which you you can find as as
as early as the 1770s in in the us
again the civil war the the
lincoln puts out
a draft notice for
i don't know how many hundred thousand
and only
very few people showed up
same thing through the war of 1812
the
the british are marching on washington
they're in maryland
madison puts out a call for 95 000
american volunteers from the states of
pennsylvania new jersey maryland and
virginia
and 5 000 showed up
so i don't think it's a warrior society
i think i think it is the interest of
the of the warriors of the nation-state
of the
uh
would-be
empire
um
to
invent wars
but then they always have a trouble
rounding up the boots on the ground i
mean that's been a except in world war
ii where we were clearly
attacked by the japanese and war
declared on us by hitler three days
later
we didn't need a lot of explanations
from colin powell as to
why we were
at war with
japan and germany
long time editor of harper's has been
our guest for in depth for the past
three hours he has 13 books under his
belt you can get the list of them by
going to our website which is booktv.org
and you can also go to
laphamsquarterly.org
to find out more about your new your new
publication which begins when again
october of this year and again the um
the premise of it is
history it's it's to frame the past and
the present and the present and the past
and to
bring to bear on the
events and the news
and the concerns in the news the
the
writing of
authors who have
proved themselves prescient or why so it
would it's the great book cement made
topical and in the meantime people can
still read you in harper's yes how often
uh every other month six times a year i
write a column for harper's magazine
thanks for spending the afternoon with
us thank you connie for
having me appreciate it very much thanks
to our viewers have a good day
join us for our next in depth on sunday
july